Ever since its discovery in 1985,
the springtime ozone hole
over Antarctica has been
an insistent reminder of
humankind’s ability to cause
environmental harm.
But the wound has begun to heal:
there is now evidence that
the hole is shrinking.
The problem began in the 1980s
with chlorine-containing
chemicals used in
dry cleaning, refrigerators, and aerosol cans.
In order to destroy ozone,
the chlorine needs
to be activated with two extra ingredients --
ultraviolet light and
stratospheric clouds
made of nitric acid particles that
only form in extreme cold.
That’s why Antarctic ozone
destruction peaks in October --
when winter cold gives
way to springtime light.
The 1987 Montreal Protocol
phased out the chemicals.
And measurements have shown them
declining in the atmosphere.
Now, researchers have found evidence
of the intended consequence:
shrinkage in the ozone hole.
Using satellites,
ground-based instruments,
and ozone-measuring weather balloons,
they showed that since 2000, the
Antarctic hole in September
shrunk by 4 million square kilometers --
an area bigger than India.
An extra challenge was
showing that the shrinkage
was due to the drop in chemicals.
Using a 3D atmospheric model,
the researchers
separated out the effects of
weather and volcanic emissions,
which can also destroy ozone.
The model helped explain anomalously large
ozone holes like the one in October 2015 -
which was largely due to the
eruption earlier that year
of the Calbuco volcano in southern Chile.
Although the hole has begun to heal,
the chlorine and bromine
containing chemicals
have long atmospheric lifetimes.
So scientists don’t expect the hole
to close up completely until
2050, at the earliest.